[Music]
all right we're finally doing this I'm
so excited thank you so much for coming
out I've been awaiting this conversation
for a very long time I'm super excited
to have both of you here today we're so
grateful thank you yeah I really
appreciate it we're big admirers of your
work as well well the the mutual
admiration society is in full effect
pioneer not just the plant based
movement but also lifestyle medicine in
general so it's truly an honor to have
you guys here thank you and excited to
get into it I think what I would like to
do what I think would be really
interesting and effective is kind of
just address some conventional ideas
that are swirling about out there and
kind of talk through them and the first
one I want to talk about is this idea
that the low-fat diet craze the low-fat
message that seemed to be conventional
wisdom throughout the 80s correct seems
have seems to have been fallen by the
wayside people are saying well that
didn't work right we we talked about
low-fat for a long time and people just
got fatter so I'd love to hear your
perspective on this sure well first of
all
unfortunately because I debated dr.
Atkins so many times and he was the
low-carb guy I got pegged as the low-fat
guy our program has never just been
about fat it's really about a Whole
Foods plant-based diet it's low in fat
and sugar and stress management moderate
exercise and what we call social support
which is really love and intimacy or eat
well move more stress less love more you
know that's it but even the idea of fat
the problem was number one you know
people say oh Americans been totally
less fat you know we're fatter than ever
low fat is dead it's all sugar but we
may have been told eat less fat but I
went to the US Department of Agriculture
database because they keep track of the
entire food supply not what people say
the reading but what they're actually
eating and oftentimes there's a big
discrepancy and what we found is that in
every decade since 1950 we may have been
told eat less fat we're eating a lot
more fat sixty-seven percent more fat
more sugar more meat and more calories
more of everything more of everything so
nuts of rezian worth
not because reading to a little fat but
because weird eating too much of
everything yes the idea is that that
it's not that the low-fat thing didn't
work it's that people didn't actually do
it and the other thing is besides
getting more fat is people when they did
replace fat they would replace it with
sugar so you have the snack well cookies
and you know the Entenmann's cakes and
things like that and that's not a good
choice right but I think if you actually
look at all of the data there's more
evidence than ever that an optimal diet
is low in fat and low in sugar it's
predominantly fruits vegetables whole
grains legumes soy products in their
natural forms and we've been doing
studies for 40 years so you know having
been in all these different diet Wars
and I debates I said you know look I'm
done you know we we've done every study
that we've done has shown that these
same lifestyle changes can reverse heart
disease we're able to show that for the
first time type-2 diabetes high blood
pressure high cholesterol obesity we're
doing another first randomized trial now
to see if we can actually reverse
Alzheimer's disease we found that when
you change your lifestyle it changes
your genes you know hundreds of genes
over 500 genes in three months turning
on the good genes
turning off the bad genes in just three
months we found that in a study we did
we published that with craig Venter who
first decoded the human genome right we
did a study with Elizabeth Blackburn it
got the Nobel Prize for discovering
telomeres the ends of our chromosomes
that regulate how long we live we've
showed for the first time that in just
three months we can increase telomerase
the enzyme that repairs and lengthens
telomeres by 30% and over a five-year
period we show it again for the first
time we can actually lengthen telomeres
in a sense reversing aging at a cellular
level so the more diseases we study and
the more underlying mechanisms we look
at the more reasons we have to explain
why these simple changes are so powerful
and how quickly people can get better
what do you think that the challenges
are are that you face in trying to
communicate this message because if you
canvass the conversations that are
occurring right now they do tend to
swirl around this you know new obsession
with eating a high-fat diet and you know
everything you ever heard about
saturated fat is wrong and people are
you know all about keto and you know
it's always there's always a new thing
coming right a new craze a new trend
this is something you've you've been
immersed in this for forty years at this
point yeah and your message really
hasn't changed from the studies that you
did so long ago to date I mean they just
sort of continue to confirm yes what
you've been saying all along well it may
seem do but it's not new I mean I've
been hearing this for 40 years it
actually goes back to the 1800s it's
really just it's an Atkins diet redux
whether it's a Atkins diet a paleo diet
a ketogenic diet it's all the same thing
and it tell first of all telling people
what I want to hear is always a good way
to sell books or magazines or newspapers
or whatever and as all there's those
media have been so disruptive they're
always looking for you know the next
thing that they can hook readers with
number two is that the studies are
showing quite clearly that yeah you can
lose weight on these diets because most
people do eat too many refined carbs and
so eating fewer refined carbs you're
gonna lose weight and Atkins and I
agreed on that it's what you replace
them with you know I'd love to be able
to tell people that you know steak and
burgers and so on are good for you but
they're not you know and if you actually
look at the the idea is to lose weight
in ways that enhance your health rather
than mortgage it and there was a study
in the New England Journal of Medicine
that Stephen Smith published a few years
ago that showed actually pictures and
what happens on different diets what
happens in your arteries um you can lose
weight with chemotherapy or smoking
cigarettes or lots of ways of losing
weight that aren't really good for you
amphetamines are a good way of losing
weight and what they found is that on a
Whole Foods plant-based diet your
arteries are clean on a typical standard
American diet which has the great
acronym of sad they're partially caught
and on a high fat high enema protein
diet whether you call it an Atkins or
keto or Paleo diet they're severely
clogged and even if their weight and
even if their blood pressure may be
lower because these often work through
what are called non traditional risk
factors things that people you know
there are little white blood cells that
nibble your arteries and keep them clean
and so on and it's not even just about
over long periods of time even a single
meal of is high in fat cholesterol can
reduce blood flow to your brain can
reduce blood flow to your heart there's
you know the movie that James Cameron
and Louie Psihoyos and others said
game-changers will be coming back soon
has this great scene with three athletes
and they give them a plant-based meal
and
measure how the the frequency and the
hardness of their erections at night
right and then they give them a
meat-based meal in the next night and
found the same and did the same thing
and they found they had three to five
hundred percent more frequent erections
on a plant-based meal than a meat-based
meal and 10 to 15 percent harder
erections the fact that I'm told the
film career became vegan after that will
definitely get guys attention right it
takes it away from this fear-based
approach like oh I can't do what I want
you know am I gonna live longer is it
just gonna seem longer all those kind of
cliches to say oh these things are so
much more dynamic than we once realized
that when you eat this way your brain
gets more blood flow you can actually
grow so many brain neurons in just a few
weeks your brain gets bigger and
particularly those parts of your brain
like the hippocampus the control memory
that you want to get bigger you know
when people get old if I sent like you
know was where I leave my keys and what
was that person's name a lot of that's
reversible your skin gets more blood so
you don't age as quickly your heart gets
more blood we found you can reverse
heart disease or sexual organs get more
blood flow and when people realize that
it's not just about living longer it's
about feeling better and improving the
quality of life it really reframes that
debate from you know fear of dying which
is not sustainable - joy of living and
feeling good and pleasure which really
are right there seems to be a lot of
confusion out there right now about
saturated fat and cholesterol for years
the consensus the scientific nutrition
consensus was that saturated fat was bad
high LDL is bad and then suddenly some
studies came out that caught the
attention of the media and there were a
lot of headlines and a lot of articles
written about this idea that everything
you ever heard about saturated fat is
wrong
cholesterol is something that we need
and it's good and you shouldn't worry
about saturated fat that actually
saturated fat is a health food so then
walk me through how we got to this point
and perhaps you know clarify the record
or share your perspective on on this
I remember I was in Davos at the World
Economic Forum two and a half years ago
when Time magazine put a sick of butter
on their cars back yeah and Nancy Gibbs
was the editor-in-chief at the time and
she was doing this one-on-one interview
with me and she said so what'd you think
of our cover and I said well not not not
so well and she said well why not and I
said well cause it's not true
you know the studies were showing that
saturated fat doubles your risk of
Alzheimer's disease for everyone one pad
of butter your risk of premature death
from all causes we look at 300,000
people in the Harvard physicians in
Harvard Nurses Health Study goes up by
5% so these things really are important
now cholesterol is good in the sense
that your body needs cholesterol it's a
building block for you know sex hormones
and nerve coverings and all kinds of
things and because precisely because
it's so important your body will make
all the cholesterol it needs the dietary
requirement for cholesterol is is zero
but getting all this extra cholesterol
you know there's we found in our studies
that there was a dose-response
relationship between the intake of
dietary cholesterol and dietary fat and
changes in the blockages in the arteries
this was also found in what was called
the the class study the David
Blankenhorn done at the USC many years
ago was one of the first studies to show
that the drugs could actually reverse
cholesterol lowering drugs could reverse
heart disease and he found that the same
dose-response relationship the more fat
you consumed including saturated fat and
especially saturated fat the more
clogged your arteries become and even a
single meal as we've been talking about
it makes a difference so you know I'd
love to be able to tell people that fat
is good that it's all sugar but it's not
an optimal diet is low in both now the
third aspect is is animal protein you
know which people in this whole fat
versus carbs debate I want to make sure
that we cover animal protein because
there's more and more evidence coming
out showing that animal protein is
inflammatory it causes chronic
inflammation it causes oxidative stress
and independent of its effect on you
know the fat versus carbs one study came
out that showed that people who ate a
lot of animal protein had a 75%
increased risk of premature death from
all causes and a 400 to 500 percent
type 2 diabetes and prostate breast and
colon cancer
so you know again people like to
simplify things and flecked like it's
all one thing it's not one thing it's
all these contents all these other
lifestyle factors as well I want to get
into the animal protein thing but but
before we do that just to kind of
continue this threat on saturated fat
explain to me the study that led to this
misconception and and you know what
there was a study that came out correct
and everybody kind of latched on to this
well there are a lot of studies that
have come out and the problem is is they
often do what are called meta analyses
where you combine and kind of love
together lots of different studies and
in science you're always trying to
answer the question is this a real
finding or is this a chance finding and
by convention if there's less than a 5%
chance of it being due to chance it's
considered statistically significant or
real finding the problem is when you
mush together a lot of different studies
there's a lot of noise people don't
always tell you the truth about what
they eat on diet studies I mean they
they tell you what they think you want
to hear so the only there's an adherence
problem there's an adherence problem but
more more than that there's a lack of
accurate information like you like
people don't want to tell you oftentimes
I mean in our studies we work with
smaller groups of people and we really
hammer them about how important it is to
tell us the truth there's no shame
there's no guilt because if you for
example I tell patients if you tell us
you're eating a healthy diet and you're
really not that it looks like the diets
not working when you're really just not
following it and so oftentimes people
don't tell us the truth about or don't
tell other people the truth about what
they're actually eating so the more
noise you have the harder it is to show
significant differences so if you've got
a lot of noise and people say oh well
saturated fat really isn't correlated
with these things because it's not
statistically significant more often
than not the real issue is because the
the information they were getting was
inaccurate in the first place mm-hmm
skewed by other data yes or it's skewed
by other data right on the animal
protein issue is it the is it something
inherent in animal protein itself or is
it everything that comes with the animal
protein like what is the difference
between how the body metabolizes the
animal protein versus plant protein or
is it like the saturated fat and
cholesterol that generally is conjoin
with the intake of animal proteins well
animal protein is is harmful and
plant-based protein is not only not
harmful it's actually protective there
are literally hundreds of thousands of
substances and fruits and vegetables and
whole grains and legumes and soy
products that have any cancer and heart
disease and anti-aging properties things
like phytochemicals bioflavonoids
carotenoids retinols isoflavone Jenison
lockaby there's a whole alphabet soup of
these things and where do you find them
with few exceptions you find them in in
plant-based foods the animal-based foods
besides being high in saturated fat and
dietary I mean you only get dietary
cholesterol in animal products is the
animal protein itself is inflammatory
and in our new book part of what the
this kind of unifying theory that we're
putting together for the first time is
why is it that these same lifestyle
changes are so powerful the more
diseases we study the more underlying
mechanisms we look at the more reasons
we have to explain why these changes are
so powerful and it's because although we
tend to think of heart disease as being
different than diabetes different than
prostate cancer and different than
Alzheimer's disease and so on the
radical idea here is this unifying
theory is that they're not they're
different expressions of the same
underlying disorder then the mechanisms
like chronic inflammation oxidative
stress over some simulation of the
sympathetic nervous system changes in
the microbiome changes in as we've been
talking about in gene expression and
telomeres and angiogenesis and each of
these mechanisms in turn is affected by
what we eat how we respond to stress how
much exercise we get and how much love
and support we have and so seem in this
larger context the animal protein
activates all of these different
mechanisms in negative ways which is
what makes it harmful in an independent
of the fact that it's also high in
saturated fat dietary cholesterol and
other things like that one of course the
animal is a secondary source of the
protein the source of the protein versus
going right to the plant source of the
protein so maybe we talked about the
protein myth of living in a plant-based
way of life well I mean you know it's
like people say oh I'm not gonna get
enough protein on a plant-based diet
then you said well ask mr. elephant you
know it's or they asked Richard you're a
living example of what can be done on a
plant-based diet I mean most most guys
would
happy to do half of what you can do yeah
the the the animal protein myth persists
the idea that you can't meet your
protein needs on a plant-based diet is
is a difficult hurdle for a lot of
people to mentally overcome and you know
I feel that question every single day
I'm sure you do is well what do you tell
people you know it's funny I have like I
just that's an always evolving response
there's either's always the retort of
like look at these gigantic herbivores
they don't have a problem but that
generally leads to yeah well they have
different digestive mechanisms and then
you have to go into the whole reason why
that's not applicable blah blah blah
I basically ask people I say well what
do you think protein is what is protein
I think most people don't even know what
it is we're just we're just parroting
you know what we've been hurt our whole
lives if you say look pretty no protein
is basically made up of these amino
acids they all are found in the plant
kingdom there's nine of them that you
can't synthesize on your own you need to
get them from foods and plant foods are
rife with those nine amino acids and
I've never had a problem I just say look
I've been doing this for 12 years I've
been able to go out and do these
athletic things I've never been hindered
at 51 almost 52 I still can build lean
muscle mass and recover quickly in
between workouts and perform at a high
level so yeah you know do your own
research on yourself well you say what
do you say just laughing because when
you say I can perform at a high level
that's like saying Michael Jordan used
to be a pretty good basketball yeah I
think I think game-changers is gone is
gonna go a long way towards changing
people's minds question yeah you know
it's true and even dietary cholesterol I
mean if you actually you know some
people eat so much dietary cholesterol
they'll say well if you have six eggs
versus four eggs it really doesn't
change your blood cholesterol level it's
because those cholesterol receptors are
already saturated but they're you know
in our studies we found there was a
dose-response correlation the more
dietary cholesterol you consume the more
arteries the more blockage we found in
the Indian people's arteries
so again your body will make all the
cholesterol you need it's the excessive
amount that leads to problems right one
of the criticisms that you've had to
weather over the years is the fact that
that I know this this new book has this
unifying theory but you've always had
this unifying theory which is that if
you want to get well and stay well and
prevent you know prevent these diseases
that are killing and disabling millions
of people every year it's not just one
thing
it's diet it's lifestyle it's exercise
it's community it's love it's
mindfulness it's stress reduction it's
all of these things and yet that has
exposed you to critique saying well see
it's not the diet it's it's it's the
fact that you know he got these people
to stop smoking and make all these other
changes so who's to say what was what
well this goes back to a larger question
of what is science and and the whole
point of science is to try to say is
this a real finding or is this a chance
finding and you know the classic way of
doing studies to say there's one
independent variable you're doing one
thing like just diet alone or just
exercise alone and then one dependent
variable we're measuring all the things
that happen because of those changes or
we give the people a drug that pill and
say what happens now if you do that with
the pill maybe you can control
everything but one thing but when you're
changing lifestyle you may think you're
just changing one thing but you're never
just changing one thing let's say we
want to put people on an exercise
program okay so half the patients are
exercising half of them done we're gonna
measure the effects on whatever on their
cholesterol or their blood pressure or
their weight or their heart disease or
whatever the problem is is that you may
think you're just doing exercise but
when you put someone on an exercise
program as I'm sure you know from your
experience they're generally exercising
in a group of people the group support
is is an important component of our
program you're giving people a positive
sense of control over their lives you're
giving them a positive expectation
you're giving them a sense of control of
what they're doing when you exercise you
become more wherever your body generally
tend to change your diet when you
exercise because you're more aware of
how what you're eating affects you and
so rather than say and there was a great
study that was done of rabbits you know
just to illustrate the point this was in
the Journal
science was generally procedures a very
often dry Journal and they had these
rabbits and they were all on the same
diet and they were all genetically
pretty much the same so they assumed
that all the rabbits would get blockages
in their arteries it was a high-fat diet
they assumed they would all get
blockages in their arteries to the same
degree but they did and they looked into
it further and they found that the
rabbits who were stacked in cages up to
the ceiling the ones up high got a lot
more blockages in their arteries in
their heart than the ones that were down
low and that didn't make any sense I
thought well maybe the air circulation
or what they couldn't come up with an
idea and finally they figured it out
the lab technician who was short when
she would feed the rabbits would play
with the ones in the lower cages because
she could reach them and play with him
and pet them and ignore the ones up high
so they did another study where they
took a group of rabbits and they put
them all again genetically the same on
the same diet but one group they left
alone and the other group they would
talk to them and pet them and play with
them and love them and then couldn't
kill them to look at their arteries and
they found they had 60 percent more
blockages in the arteries that were
ignore the rabbits of the arteries the
arteries of the rabbits that were ignore
than the ones that were touched talked
about Sunday night web even though they
were genetically comparable on the same
diet so this idea that you're only
changing one thing is a myth you're
never just changing one thing and so
honor and our approach we say look
everything that we're doing we know is
independently linked with heart disease
there's certainly a lot of evidence that
exercise is good for you the mismanaging
stress is good for you that a healthy
die is good for you that love and
support is good for you
and there's a synergy that comes when
you do all these things at the same time
so unlike most things we do as doctor is
the only side effect so these are good
ones so we're saying taken as a whole
we're getting these outcomes now to
answer your question say well how do we
know that it's not all due to exercise
and not to the diet well first of all no
studies have shown that exercise alone
or meditation alone or social support
alone can actually reverse heart disease
second we've done what are called
multiple regression analyses where we
can look at the relative contribution of
each component statistically and we
found that each component is directly
linked with the more you do these things
the more you the more closely you adhere
to the diet the more you exercise the
more meditation you do the more love and
support you have the more improvement we
measure in the arteries and in every
metric we look at and so
you know we get held to a different
standard than most studies do but the
fact is is that you know the only side
effects here are good ones and so and I
think and also in science you're always
looking at average changes in one group
versus average changes in another but
first for one person if you did like an
end of one study who's really stressed
out but eating pretty well the stress
management is gonna be more important
for someone else who's really stressed I
mean eating badly but is it so stressed
out the diet may be important so you
lump all these people together you can
say on average though these changes but
all of these things are independently
important and like I say no one has ever
shown the only diet that's ever been
shown to reverse heart disease for
example is a Whole Foods loaf
plant-based diet that's low in fat and
low in sugar right and I would just
challenge the people who are doing the
paleo or keto or Atkins or whatever name
you want to give to this to say show me
the data show me a study showing that
you can reverse heart disease on any of
those diets and I'll be the first to say
great but they don't exist in fact
studies show just the opposite are you
familiar with the carnivore diet craze
that's you know you haven't heard about
this so there's a there's a swath of
people right now that are that are
eating nothing but red meat basically
and reclaiming all kinds of health
benefits by the way remember those I
think it was met life insurance ads they
said my insurance why do you ask it was
like a piano about to land on their
heads you know how plywood has them the
same question it's a it's a weird
catch-22 because human beings by our
very nature are reductionist we want to
put things in in neat and tidy
categories and the scientific method in
order to function at its best needs to
be reductive and yet that you know
belies the truth that that these things
are much more complicated and they are
interdependent and and you know even if
you constructed the most rigorous study
of all time how are you gonna measure
the psychological impact on somebody who
begins to make a change starts to feel
better and then becomes more emotionally
invested in you know working on other
areas of their life like all of these
things
work together so here's what we're doing
in the new book okay I've been a veteran
I can't tell you how many times I
debated dr. Atkins and by the way his
autopsy was those videos on on YouTube
are awesome a lot of them I know it all
of his acolytes there Gary Taubes and
others but you know I'm done with that
you know I mean first of all dr. Atkins
autopsy report got released it shouldn't
have been but it was and it said that he
died of heart failure I mean you know he
didn't die because he slipped and landed
on his head he died because his heart
was it was in heart failure that that
says it all right there you know but in
this new book I'm saying look I've been
I'm done with all these diet Wars you
know you can go around in circles and
round and round around around we've been
doing this work for 40 years every
disease we study every mechanism we look
at it's better we were able to show we
can reverse heart disease diabetes early
stage prostate cancer by extension
breast cancer high blood pressure high
cholesterol obesity and we're now doing
the first randomized trial to see if we
can reverse Alzheimer's disease which i
think is going to work and and so the
message that we're giving to readers is
as I look it works ok the more diseases
we study the more mechanisms we look at
the more reasons we have to explain why
it works taken as a whole now we can
parse out how many angels dance on the
head of a pin you know what the relative
contribution of each component is but
the fact is is that the only side
effects of each of these things are good
ones and they work you know and so we're
basically saying look here's what we did
here's what we found and did this
fantastic section of the book on here's
how you can do it and boom that's it you
know if you don't want to do it don't do
it you know but if you want to do it
this has more science behind it than
anything run back to what you were
saying yes the intervention has remained
the same over the last 40 years and
that's says a lot in itself with all the
other fads that come and go but what has
evolved are those mechanisms and
additional diseases that we've been able
to study that have been basically
reversed with our same at lifestyle
intervention so I think that it's just a
mounting case of evidence right yeah I
want to talk about the book but I think
it would be worthwhile for for
people that are listening or washing who
who are coming into this new and
unfamiliar with both of you to track it
back to the beginning like how did you
get involved in in this field to begin
with like what made you interested in
lifestyle medicine like what was the
path that led you to this place oh gosh
long long ago in a galaxy far far yeah
hit a log cabin and could talk now that
was different life time you talk about
different life time was trying to build
our credit I personally got interested
in this when I was a freshman in college
at Rice University in Houston and almost
killed myself I was so profoundly and
suicidally depressed and there's an old
saying that when the student is ready
the teacher appears and there was an
ecumenical teacher named Swami
Satchidananda who came into our home in
Dallas and changed my life and it's a
longer story but I found I could take
all the meaning out of life I could you
know who cares what nothing matters big
deal why bother you know nothing matters
and I you know I felt like I was really
stupid and then I was you know somehow
managed to fool the admissions committee
into letting me in and now that I was
with a bunch of really smart kids it was
just a matter of time before they
figured out what a mistake they made and
letting me in but beyond that I I felt
like nothing can bring lasting happiness
I had this kind of spiritual vision that
was more than I can handle at the time
and so the combination of feeling like I
was never gonna amount to anything
because I was stupid and even if I did
it wouldn't matter anyway like I thought
well what if I had really a lot of money
or a lot of power or fame or you know
whatever that would do it and I knew
that it wouldn't and so I was ready to
do myself in so my parents had this
cocktail party for the Swami this was
back in 1972 because he'd really helped
my older sister and it walks this kind
of Central Casting view of a idea of
what a Swami should look right you know
a long white beard and saffron robes the
whole thing and it gave us thoughts on a
lecture in our living room and he
started out by saying nothing can bring
you lasting happiness which I'd already
figured out except I was about ready to
do myself in and he was he was glowing I
was like what am I missing here he went
on to say what so it probably sounds
like a New Age cliche which was that
nothing can bring that to you but we
have it already if we just stop
disturbing it and then the great irony
of life then we run after all these
things if only I had more
whatever then I'd be happy and then
until you get it you're not happy if
someone else gets it then you're really
not happy and even if you get it it's
great for a little while but then let's
see there now what it's never enough for
so what big deal so I said okay I can
always I move killing myself down to
plan B let me try this weird stuff so
part of what he said was the eat a
plant-based diet meditate exercise you
know have more love in your life
ultimately he gave me this program this
lifestyle program really came from him
that's amazing you know hold on a second
all right so did you have like hippy
parents Dallas where I was in Dallas
right so you know how did first of all
like how do your parents even know like
how to get such ad ananda to come to
your house like how it's like really my
older sister was kind of a child in the
60s and it really helped her a lot so
that when he came to dallas e of a
lecture she let them know he was in town
so they decided to have a cocktail party
for him you can imagine how weird that
was in Dallas in 1970s I'm like this is
not it's not a panga Canyon I mean it
would be weird today in Dallas but it
was especially weird back then so you're
like an 18 year old kid yeah I was 18
years old and I said okay so I want to
do this you know I couldn't even sit
still long enough to meditate so he
taught me how to do a walking meditation
you know so I changed my diet you know
radically changed my diet from eating
chilies and cheeseburgers and chalupas
and all kinds of meat five times a day
to eating a plant-based diet and trying
to meditate as best I could and and I
began to get little glimpses of what it
meant to be happy and the whole message
that he has when something is so
profound and in my limited experience is
where healing occurs at its deepest
levels is that our whole culture teaches
us that our happiness and our health we
get from outside of ourselves and then
it becomes okay how do I get all this
stuff that's gonna make me happy and
again if only I had more or blank more
money more power more Beauty more sex
more accomplishment whatever you fill in
the blank then I'd be happy but then in
the process of running after all these
things we disturb his messages you have
that already it's our nature to be happy
and healthy and not be mindful of that
and then what perhaps is that ultimate
irony
we're never running after all these
different things that we think are going
to bring us what we are what we could
have already but in the process of
running after them we disturbed what we
already have so he said that the goal of
all these various changing your diet and
spiritual practices I mean we're all
gonna die is just a question of wind so
then the question is not just how long
we live and how well we live and he
would say that the goal of all these
different spiritual practices is not
that they bring you health or they bring
you a sense of peace you have that
already we are useful and we disturb
that and get dis-ease you know we are
fine and we define ourselves by on this
on that you know you're not that we
distance ourselves and isolate ourselves
from that and so the goal of all these
things that that Ann teaches so
beautifully is to quiet down our mind
and body to experience that we have that
already and even if it's a glimpse of
that so I mean I was at the point where
I couldn't like read a headline on the
newspaper and tell you five minutes
later what it said I was so messed up
and so disturbed but then I began to try
these things I got little glimpses of
what that meant and that was enough to
kind of encourage me to do more and so
you know people would later in life he
liked to make puns people say what are
you a Hindu he'd say no I'm a nun Nell
so my favourite key on the computers
always been the undo button there
wouldn't it be nice if we had that in
our lives and yeah and now we do but so
I tried that and so I could begin to get
good glimpses of that and and it changed
my whole life and I went back to school
graduated first in my class came the
baccalaureate I mean it was and I say
that not to be selfish and as a [ __ ]
just to say I went from not being able
to read a headline and tell you five
minutes later what it said to like you
know doing extremely well so not to
interrupt you but in addition to
changing your diet and adopting some
type of meditation practice and sort of
studying his teachings like what were
the practices that you employed that
allowed you to make that shift the
spiritual practices yeah meditation
exercise you know yoga type stretching
breathing which is called pranayama
meditation deep relaxation and service
you know the all the various aspects of
yoga you know most people you have yoga
they think of just the hatha or the
stretching that's just really the
beginning they're really the goal of
yoga is and I kind of got into it
backwards you know because
the whole goal of yoga is to quiet down
our mind and body to experience on one
level that we have already everything we
need you know we're already peaceful
we're already happy until we disturb it
and that becomes a very empowering thing
because instead of blaming other people
I can say what am i doing that's
disturbing my health and well-being
because I can do something about that
not to blame but to empower now if you
take meditation even further it gives
you this direct experience of
non-duality of oneness then on one level
you're separate you know you're you and
I mean we can have fun having this
conversation
but another level we're part of
something larger that connects us all
whatever name you give to that I'm even
to give it a name is to limit what's
really essentially an ineffable or
limitless experience and he would call
that the double vision that you know
that you can see the unity and the
diversity and you can really is he like
to use the analogy of the in a movie
projector the light behind the projector
is the same and then it gets filtered
through the film and all these different
dramas and names and forms and things
but you can really only enjoy that if
you don't get caught it if you can
remember that yeah this is really fun
but ultimately we're that sense of
oneness and even the word healing comes
from the word to make whole you know
Yoga comes and writes about this comes
from the Sanskrit to yoke to unite Union
these are really old ideas that were
rediscovering so when I went back so
then I went to medical school also in
Houston at Baylor College of Medicine
and I was studying learning how to do
bypass surgeries Michael DeBakey one of
the eminent people who invented bypass
surgery one of the most eminent heart
surgeons who ever lived and we cut
people open we bypass her clogged
arteries you tell them they were cured
and we often than not they go home and
eat junk food and smoke and not manage
stress not exercise their new arteries
would clog up they come back we cut him
open again and I said so that became the
metaphor they were literally bypassing
the problem without treating the cause
and one of the nice things about being a
medical student is you're not fully
indoctrinated yet so I I I started
reading the literature you know into
these buildings called libraries and
then these things called books and you
know and I got really obsessed with it's
like in dogs and cats and pigs and
rabbits and monkeys you could cause them
to get heart disease if you put them on
a high animal protein high fat diet
or didn't let them exercise or made them
smoke or isolated them or stress them
and you could reverse it if you change
those things I said why should people be
any different and everybody thought that
was a crazy idea so I took a year off
between my second and third years of
medical school much to my parents dismay
to do a pilot study of 10 men and women
put them in a hotel in Houston that
donated their look I asked every Hotel
in Houston fine the last one said we'll
give you ten rooms and the chief of
Medicine said look there's a dumb idea
but you'll learn something go for it you
know and it worked and eight of the ten
people showed significant improvement in
their blood flow to the heart that had
never been shown and they most of them
became pain free and in fact Michael
DeBakey the heart surgeon who was
merciless to me at the time you said
what year you son I said I'm a second
year he said I was gonna be so much
harder to kick you out of school than
with these crazy ideas you have and it's
crazy that everyone thought that was a
crazy idea I was working in lab animals
why would it not work in humans that's
the thing because it just it just didn't
fit in fact he called me a couple years
ago he was 99 years old right before he
died he said I just I recognized his
Louisiana accent he said I just want to
thank you I said I almost fell over
because this is the guy who's trying to
kick me out of school of the time all
these crazy ideas I said well thank you
but why he said well because your your
ideas really kept me alive to age 99 and
I just I thought they were really dumb
at the time but I just want to thank you
and he died a few months later it was
you know so if you live long enough I
ever know
right so then I did it then I went back
and then went to Harvard and
Massachusetts General Hospital I mean
you know the things that seem so obvious
to me I remember when I was a senior
resident at the Mass General which was
the number one Hospital in the world at
the time probably still is and one of
the senior attending physicians who
wrote the textbook said Dean you mean
that you think the mind affects the body
what a stupid idea and I said looked at
him I said well sir have you ever had an
erection obvious radical yeah and then
you know they've been doing stents and
angioplasties for 40 years and then all
the randomized trials have come out
there eight of them now that show that
in stable patients they don't work they
don't prolong life they don't prevent
heart attacks
they don't even reduce angina and
they're they're dangerous invasive
expensive and largely ineffective now
they can be life-saving around middle
but profitable but very profitable
that's the thing
and so you know it's it's it it's not
enough to have good science that's why I
spent 16 years to get Medicare to
reimburse our program because through my
nonprofit Institute we were training
hospitals and clinics around the country
we got bigger changes in lifestyle
better clinical outcomes bigger cost
savings better adherence and a number of
the sides closed because we didn't have
the reimbursement so that sent me on a
16-year journey to get Medicare coverage
which I'm grateful that they did they
created a new benefit category and now
most of the insurance companies are
paying for it so we were now training
sites and really trying to create this
whole new paradigm of health care yeah
that's a that's a big deal when it
becomes reimbursable by the insurance
companies I'm sure that was a tall
mountain to climb oh it was like 16
years I had no idea be so hard but if
it's reimbursable that it's sustainable
right and so you know I'm really
grateful that we were able to do that
but it was the hardest thing I've ever
done and I want to bring you into this
so how do you enter the equation here
well I was in many ways I mean I didn't
I've worked together for 20 years and
I'm the director of our our nonprofit as
far as developing EMR is preventive
medicine research institute that works
so I direct program development and one
of the ways I do that is the digital
platform so I've built a learning
management system that is what trains
the healthcare providers to have a
turnkey way to deliver this program at
all the hospitals and clinics around the
country yeah across the country and then
they're also the core curriculum for
participants to attain that health
literacy to go from you know what are
the nuts and bolts of living this way
ultimately until nine weeks later really
learning why do I want to live longer
and I think that's something that I
would love to touch on because you know
I think a lot of times fear is the
motivator when we're working to reverse
a condition people will have a diagnosis
or some kind of pain trauma that brings
them into this way of living but then
what really allows them to continue this
way of living for
the rest of their lives is to ask
themselves the question and it's a
unique answer for each of us is why do
you want to live longer and Dean started
saying you know when he was 18 he was so
severely depressed which isn't another
epidemic in our country you know first
is you know many people don't even
really want to live longer so I think
that is a really core question and I
think going deeper into that inquiry is
to say not only to live longer but to
live better and so initially it might be
I want to have the pain stop I want to
you know kind of have the rest of my
life to look forward to so then the
question is what what is the the meaning
the sense of purpose that's driving you
to get up every day and I just think
that's so core because again it's not
something outside of ourselves it's not
your doctor or your spouse telling you
you should do this this is the good
thing to you know this would be good for
your health that only works for so long
it really has to come from the inside
and we have to identify with what that
is for us personally and then we need to
kind of read up with that and amplify
that throughout our days with every
choice that we make
let me just build on that real quickly
because earlier we're talking about how
I could take all the meaning out of
everything when I was so depressed but
later I learned we can actually put
meaning into our lives we can imbue our
choices with meaning and one way is by
choosing not to eat certain foods for
example I think that's why all religions
all spiritual paths almost all of them
have dietary guidelines and they're
often in conflict with each other one
religion you can eat this but not that
or certain days of the week or certain
times a day or certain months of the
year whatever is God confused I don't
know but whatever intrinsic benefit
there is in making diet and lifestyle
changes just the act of choosing not to
eat something that you otherwise could
do or attack the act of say I'm going to
be in a monogamous relationship or
whatever is that deprivation well it can
be that's often how it's portrayed or is
it first of all what I gain is so much
more than what I give up but beyond that
because these underlying biological
mechanisms are so dynamic but beyond
that it's like just the act of choosing
not to do something like not to eat
certain foods makes them imbues those
choices with meaning and makes those
choices say huh
not sacred in the boring sense but the
most special the most fun the most
erotic the most pleasurable the most
meaningful you know Viktor Frankl wrote
this book years ago called man's search
for meaning and he interviewed
concentration camp survivors in the most
dire circumstances and he found that the
ones who lived weren't necessarily the
strongest or the healthiest they were
the ones you have the strong a sense of
meaning and purpose like I have to
survive so that I can you know be
reunited with my loved ones or bear
witness whatever happened to be just
like Anna's talking about so when people
enter our program one of the first
questions we ask them is why do you want
to live longer people go oh no one's
ever asked me that before I you know
yeah I think that that that goes
directly to the crux of so much of what
ails us as a society yeah as a culture
and systemically we're not raised or
taught to think in those terms I think
it's the opposite led us to a grand
crisis of consciousness that is really
fueling this epidemic of depression and
suicide yes you can clean up your diet
and eat a plant you have the most
pristine plant-based diet and that will
I believe catalyze other changes in your
life it will have this effect that will
spill over and hopefully leading you to
a more purposeful direction in your life
but if you get stuck on the food and
think that's gonna solve all your
problems you're missing the big picture
and I really I'm so glad to hear you say
that because I really think that that is
you know more important than any of the
you know epidemiological studies or meta
analyses it's like if you can't find
purpose and fulfillment in your life
then nothing else what else what else
matters well that's the point and so
much of what we see now is you know and
I ask people in our studies because we
would live together for a month at a
time in our earlier studies or meet
regularly for years at a time but say
you know teach me something why do you
smoke why do you overeat why do you
drink too much why do you abuse opioids
why do you work too hard why do you play
so many video games these behavior
behavior seem some maladaptive to me
they kind of look to me they go you
don't get it do you these behaviors
aren't maladaptive they're very adaptive
because they help us deal with our pain
our loneliness our depression you know
there's been a radical disruption in our
in our culture in the last 50 years with
a with the disruption of the social
not works it used to give people that
sense of connection and community most
people don't have a neighborhood that
feels you know with two or three
generations of people or a job that
feels secure where you've been there for
ten years or you know an extended family
you see regularly or a church or
synagogue and what we're learning is
that people say things like I've got 20
friends in this pack of cigarettes and
they're always there for me you're gonna
take away my 20 friends what are you
gonna give me or you know you know not
only why do you want to live longer but
the compass of that is self-reflection
and self-awareness and if we have that
as much throughout the day so that we
can connect the dots between what we're
feeling what we're thinking and what
we're doing and then that feedback loop
of how that makes us feel so you know
for somebody who's crutching along with
their 20 friends in their practice
cigarettes or the video games or
whatever it is it's numbing them and
really the next level for them is like
that's just kind of my getting by
standpoint but if you really look what's
below the numbing which is what's you
know what's really where the the locus
of control is and where the
transformation takes place really is
that if you can connect the dots that
those things aren't actually moving the
needle of you feeling any better
right or you growing in any way and so
the moment that you identify or that you
know I identify you know what my kind of
personal roadmap of meaning is order my
values who are the people that I want to
be spending my time with how do we spend
quality time well I have to feel good in
order to spend quality time with the
people I love and to do things with them
so it comes from that place of of self
awareness because if you realize that
underneath whatever numbing mechanism
has allowed you to cope that you're
actually not feeling well enough to do
the things that are most enlivening to
you then the way to repattern
that is just a it happens in the mind
which just really happens even deeper in
the hearts so yeah
it's it's a it's difficult for people to
grasp that though it's a very ephemeral
concept like if you tell somebody look
you got to cut out the cheeseburgers or
you got to quit smoking like they can
wrap their head around that it's very
tactile
you know tangible thing that they can
execute on but when you're like look you
got to go on this inward journey you
know like look I'm just trying to you
know get my kids home from school gives
me that get through the day and you know
somebody who's who's been in recovery
for many years you know one of the
things that you've learned very early is
that the drugs and the alcohol aren't
the problem they're the solution to the
problem you can take away the drugs and
the alcohol but then you got a deal with
the underlying condition that compelled
you to numb yourself out in that way so
you could tell somebody you got to quit
smoking but yeah that's their best
friend that you're removing from them
and if that person doesn't have the
support or the tools to then address the
underlying condition that was driving
them to you know check out that's right
whether it's a video game or your phone
or gambling or sex or whatever it is
then that person is gonna lapse back
into that behavior or they're gonna be
very unhappy you know there's you know
they're gonna see that's why that's why
we've learned it's not enough to get
people information alone if it were
nobody would smoke it's not like I say
it's not an actual thing rich I want you
to quit smoking it's bad for you go oh I
didn't know smoking is bad for everybody
but it's bad for it's on every pack of
cigarettes you have to say why do you
smoke and it's not enough to focus on
the behavior we need to work at this at
a deeper level and so in our program we
have support groups and the support
groups are not like helping people say
on the diet or exchanging recipes or
types of running shoes it's really
creating a safe environment to replicate
what people had when they grew up you
know when you grow up in an extended
family or a neighborhood with two or
three generations of people they know
you they don't just know your facebook
profile or your biosketch for all your
warrants or whatever they know where you
messed up and and you know that they
know and they know that you know that
they know there's just something
profound it's like in James Cameron's
wonderful phone avatar it's like I see
you you know it's like I don't just see
you which is really from an African
proverb it's not I just see your
biosketch I see where you messed up and
I'm still there for you
and there's something really primal
about that need for really authentic
intimacy in fact there's a sudden came
out a few months ago that the more time
you spend on Facebook the more depressed
you are why is that because it's not
authentic it's it's like it looks like
it looks like everybody has this perfect
life but you you know because people
don't post all my kids on drugs or ho
I'm having problems in my marriage
around whatever but in our support
groups that's what we what people talk
about we encourage people to say what
are you really feeling express it as a
feeling as is our feelings that connect
us and it's so easy to make fun of that
all that sounds so touchy-feely it is
that you feel like we are touchy-feely
creatures we're creatures of community
that's how we've survived as a species
and so for someone to say gosh you know
I may look like the perfect father but
my kids on drugs or heroin or whatever
and if someone's l say gosh what am I
feeling when I hear that oh that sounds
terrible I'm so sorry to hear that I
used to have a drug problem they might
say well gosh my kid has another problem
well it doesn't solve the issue but it
suddenly you don't feel so isolated and
study after study have shown that people
who are lonely and depressed or three to
ten times more likely to get sick and
die prematurely from pretty much all
causes when compared to those who have a
sense of love and connection community
and I don't know anything even diet that
has that big an impact or smoking and
now they all interrelate because you're
much more likely as you both have said
to to choose those behaviors to numb it
out just to kind of deal with that pain
but if you're numb out pain you also
numb out pleasure so you kind of have
this kind of great life and what what if
people remember anything else about this
wonderful podcast that we're having
today is to say that the point of our
program is not to help people live
longer it's to live better as Anne was
saying because you know there's no point
in giving up something that you enjoy
unless you get something back that's
better and quickly and because these
underlying biological mechanisms are so
dynamic when you change your lifestyle
and ironically it's sometimes easier to
get people to make big changes all at
once because when you make big changes
in your lifestyle you feel so much
better so quickly it reframes the reason
for making those changes from fear of
dying or if you're something bad
happening or just numbing to get through
the day to joy and pleasure and feeling
good and you know and it gets into a
virtuous cycle where you start to feel
better and better you want to build on
that at all yeah just to say that
all of these the four pillars of the
lifestyle are equally weighted in the
sense of what we've been talking about
about the synergy of those things and
when we talk about the the Lovemore
component of the the book and the
program its first it comes back to that
self-awareness which is really the
Stressless components and so we start
with the physical body to start to on a
physical level kind of unwind it calm it
down then we get to the the mind and we
get to see what is the the climate of
the of the thinking pattern there is it
racy is it calm and as we get it to that
place of calm then we get to to drop
into how are we actually feeling and so
very often people never get to the
feeling place they're just still in the
thinking place which they could be
debating themselves in their own brain
forever and never really more than
another place yeah and or the numbing
place and so along the continuum of you
know in that same spirit I always say
that the diet if you will is the sort of
like the Trojan horse of the lifestyle
that it's the one thing that we have to
do you know three times a day and so if
we can solve for that then we get people
on this kind of moving sidewalk of
living better and they start to feel
better they're like I want to get up and
start moving some more and then they
start moving more and then they are in
their body as dean sane and then they
start to have a sense of wow i have no
idea what was going on inside which then
we go further into the stress less
component where we have more of that
self reflection we heighten that sense
of self-awareness and then we bring that
into our relationships and the love more
component so they really all do kind of
build but it's from the inside out and
that's so talk it all about in terms of
what you gain is so much more than what
you give up in terms of being in a
committed relationship and the things
that we're learning about that i think
just as one more
example of you know going further in
going deeper instead of going wider in
all of our pursuits to the extent that
were looking far and wide far needs to
be met we spent a lot of our bandwidth
from their time well I'm just I'm first
I'm saying just in general I think in a
way a way of living and approaching life
that if we're looking out for it outside
of ourselves and as many varieties as
possible which can be fun from a from
and at some stamp points then we're not
going deeper and so I love the analogy
of you know kind of digging up too many
different holes looking for water but
kind of giving up after you know you get
to say three feet versus going down say
you know who how far far down to eat
reach that wellspring and I think that's
analogous to relationships and whether
we're just going deeper with the
relationships we have in all facets of
our life but I think especially
romantically I think it's a level of
intimacy in the in that sense that
allows well level of vulnerability that
is really the key to go deeper is to
allow ourselves to be more vulnerable to
ourselves and to those around us and if
we do that with our primary spouse or
partner that level of intimacy is just
an infinite kind of frontier really and
I think that is something in my
experience is impossible to experience
simultaneously while continuing to look
and manage other relationships the other
go so that I can only speak personally
that's something that Dean and I reflect
on is how initially when we got together
and we really realized wow this is my
true love the search is off that it felt
like there was this upwelling of so much
life force that had been previously this
person dispersed and yes out into the
the searching mode
versus the dropping in mode and to build
on that part of what I'm learning is
that you know and the other thing that's
besides the keto diets and so on is this
whole polyamorous thing that's going on
especially in the tech world and you
know it's not a moral judgment it's like
okay what really brings you the most
happiness and part of what I'm learning
is having tried a number of different
things is that the more intimate it is
the more erotic it becomes and instead
of having the same kind of a superficial
experience with different people you can
end up having the most incredibly varied
and erotic experiences with the same
person that keep the relationship so
fresh and juicy and fun because as Ann
says you can only be intimate to the
degree you can be vulnerable and open
your heart and you can only do that to
degree you feel safe so the paradox is
that when you're in a committed
relationship it allows a sense of safety
that allows like the layers of an onion
the heart to keep opening wider and
wider and wider and the more open the
heart is the more erotic and pleasurable
it becomes I just want to say from a
yogic perspective it's it's about
integration ultimately the path to peace
and happiness if you will is a matter of
feeling fully integrated so we have so
many facets of our self and we have to
play different roles in different ass
parts of our life but to the extent that
we have relationships with a
relationship primarily with our self but
with others that reflect our our
wholeness that in itself is healing to
the yes yeah it requires a huge amount
of work to get to that place to to be
able to have that kind of depth of
intimacy and and safety you know one of
the things Julie and I always talk about
is is this idea that in most
relationships we project an idealized
version of our partner on to that person
and we're really in a social contract
right like I love you but in your mind
you're like well I love you as long as
you're this this this and this in a
minute that you stop being those things
like I will retract my love right and
that is a transactions business this
habit that's always said we used to say
that's not love that's business right
yeah yeah
so how do you transcend that to come to
this place where you're where you're
able to love your partner in a more
unconditional way and I think if you
know if you can get to that place then
that person feels safe and they can be
vulnerable because they feel they feel
like if they're vulnerable they're not
going to either be judged or abandoned
what's deeper than that is that you're
loving yourself unconditionally it's a
it's much harder to love somebody else
unconditionally that those kind of
barriers are ultimately barriers that
we're having with accepting ourselves so
it's actually something so it's like I
don't even want to admit to myself that
I don't if I part but the nice thing
about being best friends right yours
before we became lovers is that you'll
share things with your best friend you
would never share if you're just dating
it's like wow you know that about me you
still love me
it's very liberating in that way and so
it it's like a subset of the larger
issue about oh and it's so deprived I
can't eat meat I can't eat that is is
that the ball and chain if you're in a
committed monogamous relationship well
it can be but it can also be the the
crucible of safety that allows both
people to open their hearts more and
more which makes it that much more
erotic and intimate I worked my way
through school as a photographer and
first sighs doing these big portrait
photography from like the ages of 12 to
14 and on you know kind of manipulating
images and lighting and retouching and
airbrushing this is before Photoshop to
make people look better than they were
and then I started I actually studied
for a couple of years with a well-known
photographer named Gary winter grant one
of the great photographers of the 20th
century it would just take a little like
a little and just to go around and just
see things as they are and not trying to
change them into what you want them to
be and you put a picture on the wall you
say what do you see if people say oh I
see this they say well how do you know
someone have a gun around let's have the
frame or how do you know this or how do
you know that just to try to challenge
people's preconceptions what suzuki
called beginner's mind you know to
really see things fresh without
preconceptions which is where true
innovation as opposed to imitation comes
from and that kind of beginner's mind to
be able to see without preconceptions is
where things are the most creative and
so when and I have a date we're not
trying to recreate an experience that
we've had before however one
while that might have been were open to
all possibilities all degrees of freedom
we try to approach that with beginner's
mind just say I totally trust you I
surrender to you let's see where this
goes and just follow the energy and it's
just so much more interesting and erotic
and pleasurable than anything I've ever
even imagined much less experience
beforehand yeah and so there it is at
the ball and chain know it's anything
but that so you've been eating a
plant-based diet people say oh my god
how can you do that you must you must
not like food are you you must feel so
deprived you say well actually no
because what I gain is so much more than
what I give up
right not preventing something bad 30
down 30 years down the road but right
here right now and we're always making
choices and so to me part of the value
of science and why we spent 40 years
doing research is that it can redefine
what's possible for people awareness is
always the first step in healing and it
can raise awareness like if you're
willing to do these things your chest
pain will go away so if you can't walk
across the street without getting chest
pain because you've got heart disease or
make love with your spouse or play with
your kids or go back to work then within
a few weeks you can do all those things
people say things like yeah I like
eating meat but not that much because
what I gained is I was more than what I
give up yeah there there's this that's
why ascetic practices breed free you
know that's why they've survived over
millennia right because there's
something about the giving up that abuse
those choices with meaning as well yeah
all right so that took a look that's a
good term we're talking about polyamory
experience you know parts of my life
like that it's about saying okay I mean
when I decided not to kill myself when I
was you know we would kind of go full
circle I said okay I don't know what's
real I don't know who to trust
I'm gonna lead a messy life because I
need to find out for myself what's true
and I'm gonna make a lot of mistakes I'm
a lot of doing stupid things and I'm
gonna learn from them and as long as not
going to hurt me permanently or hurt
someone else I'm gonna try a lot of
different things because there's a lot
of wisdom that comes from making
mistakes and learning from it and in
working with people who are dying now
that I'm a doctor they generally don't
regret with a dead they generally got
what they didn't do because if you do
something and it turns out to be really
a dumb idea there's a lot of wisdom that
comes from making mistakes and learning
from then you really know but if you
don't do it you just kind of wonder you
have regrets
I said I don't want to have those kind
of regrets and so it's not a value
judgment it's not a moral issue it's not
a you know right or wrong it's like oh
these are the things that enable us to
live certainly in our lives and I think
and many others many many others that
we've worked with these were choices
that enable us to live a life that's
just joyful and pleasurable and fun and
exciting and adventuresome as opposed to
being depressed and boring and and you
know all of that kind of stuff so what
you gain is more than what you give up
it takes it out of the realm of a value
judgment or a moral issue or your bad or
whatever and just like oh this is the
way to live the most joyful life I love
spiritual teachers like the Dalai Lama
you know and he said my religion is
happiness you know or be kind when it's
at whenever possible it's always
possible you know though the people that
embody that kind of wisdom you can feel
it just being around them that's why you
want I mean that's why George Lucas
sample the the dalai lama's laughs for
Yoda you know because it's just such a
joyful just the under vibrational level
you just feel it I I just love that this
it's empowering you know there are so
many things that were selling pills what
have you out there in the world they're
saying I've got this solution that's
outside of you and I'm gonna give it to
and you're gonna pay me but then you're
gonna need to come back for more I love
that these are concepts of how you can
choose you choose with your free will
like the most important thing how to
live your life and that's the more that
you have the feedback loop experience of
I'm feeling better and better the more
making these choices then it's coming
and all the side effects are good ones
it's self generated it's exactly right
and the other thing that happens is when
you're really quiet your mind to body
down you become more in touch with your
inner teacher you know that's still
small voice within that speaks very
clearly but very quietly it gets drowned
out by the chatter of everyday life it's
the one that wakes you up and says and
3:00 in the morning says hey Dean listen
up pay attention you're not you're
missing something yeah and I've learned
I can access that voice much more
directly so at the end of a meditation
or a yoga class or whatever or a run
when I my mind is more quiet to say I'll
ask that voice what am I missing what do
i what am I not paying attention to that
I need to pay attention to and listen
and it's all of the
studies that we've done all the creative
things that I've done in my life I've
learned to really trust that voice
because and we all have that and so one
of the nice side effects of meditating
you know the ancient Swami's and rabbis
and priests and monks and nuns didn't
develop these techniques to UNK all
their arteries or lower their blood
pressure they're really tools for
quieting down our mind and body to
experience that inner sense of peace and
joy and well-being and to gain access to
that inner wisdom and ultimately to
transcend that and have that double
vision of interconnectedness as well as
the separateness that we it truly is our
birthright it might sound very new agey
but actually there's no greater wisdom
than our inner wisdom nobody knows what
the feedback loop of you know our
thoughts our feelings our behaviors what
the actual where the rubber hits the
road inside ourselves so ultimately to
empower people with the tools and
support to empower themselves and just
to build on that when you see that
interconnectedness and then the other
aspects of eating a plant-based diet
that you've spoken so eloquently about
you know that what's good for you is
good for the planet you know more global
warming is caused by livestock
consumption than all forms of
transportation combined all the
suffering that comes from eating meat
you know if that's all you have you know
eat meat but whereas the Swami used to
say if you're in a crash on a Himalayan
mountain and you know your fellow
passengers are dead you know eat them
you know but if you have all these great
fruits and vegetables you don't have to
create suffering you don't have to you
can you know I used to get in friendly
debates with Al Gore and he became a
vegan not just because of me but because
he realized that more global warming is
because it's caused by livestock
consumption and he's a rancher than all
forms of transportation combined but
also I was on the board of the San
Francisco Food Bank for a few years and
I was because I was shocked to hear that
more than one out of five kids in the
Bay Area goes to bed hungry every night
he was up with all the prosperity that's
just pitiful but you know when when we
learned that it takes 14 times more
resources to make a pound of meat based
protein than plant-based protein there's
enough food today to feed everyone no
one need go hungry and so it's so easy
to feel overwhelmed like what can I do
is one person with global warming or
feeding the hungry or whatever and when
you realize that something is primal is
what we put in our mouths every day
while we eat
amuse those choices with meaning to say
okay I'm gonna have you know Susie
Cameron has this her book OMD coming out
one meal a day just you know I'm just
gonna have one meal a day that's
plant-based it's good for me it's good
for my family it's good for my community
it's good for my planet it imbues those
choices with meaning and as Ann said so
eloquently if it's meaningful than its
sustainable yeah I think it speaks to
you know the level of disenfranchisement
that most people feel like they don't
feel like they have agency over their
lives they don't feel like they're in
conscious control of the direction of
their lives and they don't feel like the
choices that they that they have can
have meaning outside of their little
cloistered existence and if you can
really help people to understand that
those choices do have significance and
meaning and that you know every dollar
that you spend on the food that you eat
every day has ramifications and if you
invest those dollars more mindfully that
you can be doing what's not just right
for yourself but right for the planet
and perhaps spare some animals along the
way I mean it's rigged to set in motion
this cascade of positive impacts and I
think when you can really connect with
that when you can quiet your mind and
and and really connect with you know
deeper consciousness and and come to
that still place you begin to understand
and realize that you know your footprint
can make a difference and that's a
beautiful thing and I think that that is
the the the fertilizing of a sense of
agency that we all feel like we we are
lacking right now so many people
beautifully said by the way to transcend
that it's not a matter of blame it's a
matter of empowering yes because
otherwise I remember when I've been
working with President Clinton since 93
when Hillary asked me to train the
chef's to cook for them at the White
House and then Camp David in Air Force
One I come in for his annual physical
but that's Naval Hospital and then about
ten years ago he had his bypass has
clogged up and his car one of his
cardiologist held a press conference
said it was all in his genes right and I
said him a no and I said it's not all in
your genes and I say that not to blame
but to empower you because if it's all
in your genes then you're a victim and
you're not a victim any one of those
powerful guys on the planet that's when
he began eating a plant-based diet he's
been doing you know is he still on it
how he's doing
yeah I just saw Hillary a couple days
ago and he's still on it and he's doing
well and his heart disease he's talked
about publicly that it's getting better
and if you know whatever your politics
when a former president United States
especially one who is known for not
eating yet hopefully can make these
changes and I think it inspires everyone
yeah a transformation which you're such
an incredible testimony of really what's
possible at any stage you know we've had
you know a dozen people that get off the
heart-transplant list in the past year
yeah one of them here's UCLA doctor
himself we wrote about in the book named
Bob Troy hearts who is ejection for you
know the heart pumps blood and the
ejection fraction is the percentage of
blood that it pumps with each beat so
normally it should pump at least half
the what's in there 50% is than the
normal or higher and his ejection
fraction after a massive heart attack
was down around 11 to 13 percent it was
barely pumping and he was told he was
going to die and he said the only thing
that could save him maybe would be a
heart transplant and while waiting for a
donor he went through our program at
UCLA you know that we've been training
around the country and in nine weeks his
ejection fraction improved from 11% to
30% so and now it's even higher and so
he got off the heart transplant list we
have over a dozen people like that so
you people say Aldine you have his
radical program looks like compared to a
- oh yeah and I remember when we were in
these 16 years we're trying to get
Medicare to cover the program at met
with one of the heads of Medicare at the
time and he said Dean we have to get a
letter from the head of the national
heart law - well the head of the
National Heart Lung and Blood Institute
of the National Zoo's of health at that
it's safer people to older people to
walk meditating vegetables and since my
loved one yeah I don't blink an eye when
when we're gonna crack we actually had
to do that it's so it's like the
systemic
you know problems that that you know you
have to overcome to scale what you're
doing but let's just look at what's
going on I mean when you talk about
heart disease one out of every two
people will suffer from some form of
heart disease one out of every three is
gonna die from it
eighty percent of American adults are
fils or overweight one-third of kids are
diabetes like half of the population
diabetic or pre-diabetic I mean it is
banana even when you look at depression
which our program isn't you know set out
to be an antidepressant but yet it is
actually more powerful than some of the
depressant depression scores are cut in
half yeah but that's part of the
opportunity you know is that I mean it's
hard doing this work but ninety-nine one
studies show the epic study show the 93
percent of people that have diabetes is
preventable today I think it's closer to
ninety nine percent of time to type 2
diabetes that's right it's not like we
don't know what to do but there are all
these myths around there oh you know I
can get my patients to take their their
statins to lower the cholesterol there's
no way they're gonna change their
lifestyle and yet this pharma companies
own data show that only have to have -
only a third to half of people who are
prescribed statins are taking them just
four months later and yet we're getting
94 percent of the 72 hours of our
program people are actually able to do
and a year later 85 to 90% of the people
are still following you it's the support
though right it's the support in the
follow up well it's the support but also
we've learned that fear is not a
sustainable motivator but joy and
pleasure and feeling good and freedom
are and when someone says here take this
pill this is this cholesterol-lowering
drug it's not gonna make you feel better
hopefully it won't make you feel worse
to prevent something really awful like a
heart attack or stroke from happening
years down the road and so people like
after someone's had a heart attack
they'll do pretty much anything that the
doctor says for like maybe a month or
maybe two and that's it because they
don't want to think that something Bad's
gonna happen to them so they don't you
know we're all going to die but we don't
think about it most of the time but when
you change your lifestyle because these
mechanisms are so dynamic and one of the
biggest obstacles we have to face all
the time is people think we're we're
doing it today that prevents something
really bad from happening down the road
and say no no you will probably help
prevent something down the road but
you're doing it today because you'll
feel so much better because these
mechanisms are so much more dynamic and
that really reframes the reason for
change from fear of dying which is not
sustainable - joy of living which is and
the sense of meaning and purpose and is
that virtuous circle it's pleasurable
and if it's meaningful that it's
sustainable well we're seeing the rise
of lifestyle medicine
more and more people are practicing
medicine in this way that you you have
been doing it for for a long time but
systemically we still have major
obstacles yes that prevent this from
being the norm most doctors well
intentioned you know got into medicine
to help people but they're stuck in a
system where they have 15 minutes to see
somebody 10 is it 10 minutes sometimes 8
they're incentivized to you know just
diagnose and prescribe and move on to
the next one and you know from my
perspective we're not going to solve
these problems until we change the
system and and start incentivizing
practices like yours that are providing
the real care that the patients need to
to develop that sense of agency to go on
this path to get the support you know to
be able to build in all of these
lifestyle practices that can prevent I
couldn't that's why I spent 16 years as
I mentioned we we trained all these
sites before we had the reimbursement
even though we got these great outcomes
some of them closed down that was the
painful lesson that it's not enough to
have good science not good enough to
have good clinical outcomes it was not
reimbursable it's not sustainable it's
follow the money you know or crazy Eddie
Money talks nobody walks or the rappers
you know it's all about the Benjamins
whatever and so but now because we do
have Medicare coverage and most of the
major insurance companies recovering in
we're creating a new paradigm of
lifestyle medicine which is using
lifestyle changes that would help
prevent but even to reverse the most
common chronic diseases and it's working
and as I mentioned we're getting bigger
changes in lifestyle better clinical
outcomes bigger cost savings better
adherence and you know the American
College of lifestyle medicine which I
helped found you know it has over a
thousand fifteen hundred doctors you
know it keeps going up exponentially
every year at the annual meetings it's
it's the most exciting trend in medicine
today and it's a wave that hasn't even
begun to crest and so when you change
medium bursts when you change medical
practice and even medical education and
our approach leverages the doctors time
so instead of having a patient you see
every 10 minutes which most doctors you
know wouldn't recommend medicine as a
career for their kids it's not fun for
the doctor if you have to spend you know
you basically go through the electronic
medical record you listen the heart
lungs you're on a prescription they're
out the door it's not fun for the doctor
or the patient but
we have 72 hours that Medicare is paying
for and we work with a doctor but also a
nurse a meditation teacher I mean who
would have thought Medicare be paying
for yoga meditation a dietitian and
exercise physiologist and a psychologist
so people come twice a week for four
hours at a time for nine weeks they get
an hour of supervised exercise an hour
of yoga and meditation and our support
group and our group me with a lecture
and then after they finish their nine
weeks then and brilliantly develop this
video conferencing way of continuing the
support group so they can all using the
technology called zoom where they'll say
okay like from 5:00 to 6:00 on Thursdays
we'll all zoom in together and they have
their support group because they've
already bonded with each other and
that's why we're getting unprecedented
levels of adherence because that sense
of community is so powerful and it's so
meaningful for people especially because
you know we don't really often have
places where we can be authentic with
each other in those ways and clearly you
know if you're able to enroll in our
very high touch program where you have
clinical support and the support of a
cohort around you that's optimal at the
same time it's like we had a new
electrician at our house this week and
I'm gonna tell you this but he as he
finished up his job and he's leaving he
says you know every single person on my
family has died of some heart related
issue before the age of 50 so at age 35
I got your husband's book and I read it
and you know I'm now like you know in
his early 50s he had passed that 50
benchmark and he just he never had the
clinical team around him he never had a
cohort of people who he was in a support
group with but he was able to read the
book and empower himself and we hear
with these kinds of stories all the time
so it's not to say that you're dependent
again on on that I would say I guess I'd
say I'm shocked except he was
electrician but it
but the when we started working together
in the late 90s with WebMD it was such a
transformative time for just the medical
field I felt in the sense that we were
coming out of a era of the passive
patients just listening to the sermon
from the white jackets their white coat
but more empowering ourselves becoming a
better educated more informed consumer
of our healthcare and so so often you
know participants patients are coming to
their annual exam saying these are the
things that I've noticed about myself
these are the things that I think would
help what do you think you know and so
there really are taking that agency more
and more and I think that is along with
the reimbursement we're working it from
the bottom up and the top down so fun to
practice medicine this way you know
people they say see lives change right I
mean I can't imagine the transformations
you must have when most people are
prescribed drugs to lower their
cholesterol their blood pressure their
blood sugar they say how long do I have
to take this doctor what does the doctor
say forever arrest your life and all
these other medications that deal with
the side effects of yes exactly
we find we can and again kids you know
make sure you do this on your doctor's
supervision but most people can reduce
or get off of these medications that
they were told they'd have to take the
rest of their life it's incredibly
empowering because you know if every day
you're taking these pills it kind of
that becomes your meditation oh I'm sick
I'm sick I'm sick I've take all these
pills and when people can actually
reduce or get off these medications and
their chest pain goes away in extreme
examples they're hardly there they don't
need a heart transplant you know where
they can avoid prostate surgery or
whatever then they go wow I'm getting
better and they get into this virtuous
cycle which makes them just that much
more empowered in other aspects of their
life the pharmaceutical companies can't
be that happy about this though well
cars are like how does that work well
I'm always careful to say look drugs
drugs and surgery have their place and
we've all benefited for them you know
and certainly in a crisis they can be
life-saving but and sometimes when
people are just beginning to change
their lifestyle the drugs are absolutely
necessary until the lifestyle changes
begin to take effect so it's not this
that it's fun it's using one things when
they're most appropriate but unfortunate
what the drug company say well okay try
let's say you've got high cholesterol
try diet first quote unquote but they
know the diet that you're gonna try is
you know less red meat more fish and
chicken take the skin off the chicken
four eggs a week and your cholesterol is
gonna go down maybe 5% or 8% they say
well you fail diet now you have to go on
these drugs the rest of your life but
what we found is that the average LDL
cholesterol went down by 40% that's
comparable to what you get with statins
but without the cost and without the
side effects except for the good ones
right
the next evolution beyond lifestyle
medicine seems to be genomics and
personalized medicine like where do you
see this heading and like we're way out
right now it's well I mean I was on
Craig Venters board for many years and
learned a lot about genetics and
genomics and personalization and so on
and if you're talking about a targeted
immunotherapy for you know a particular
type of melanoma that's that's awesome
but for the vast majority of chronic
diseases the whole point of our new book
is to say you know I shared Google
health with Marissa Meyer back in 2007
to 2009 who went on to become the CEO of
Yahoo and we were trying to come up with
these really complex algorithms to say
you know how can we personalize the diet
and lifestyle intervention and one day I
said you know and if you ever these
moments where you just realize where
this is not working you know and I
realized that the science isn't there
but even if it were I mean there was a
study that came out in JAMA last year
from Stanford where they tried to
personalize diets and they found that
didn't really matter and what this new
book that we wrote about is to say you
don't need to personalize it for most
chronic diseases because it's these same
mechanisms that underlie all of them and
let's say some people are genetically
able to metabolize dietary refined carbs
better than someone else can but if
you're not eating that many to begin
with those differences don't matter I
mean look at China like in the China
study or in Japan where the whole
country is eating a diet that's
basically plant-based low-fat low-sugar
and they have you know almost
non-existent at the time 50 60 70 years
ago heart disease was as rare there as
malaria is here then they start to eat
like us and live like us and now die
like us for they moved to this country
and they their rates of heart disease
and prostate and breast and colon cancer
the same as ours there
jeans didn't change but the expression
of those genes changed and so the point
of our new book is that you don't really
need to personalize it that if that
these same lifestyle changes reverse all
of these different chronic conditions
because they all share the same
underlying mechanisms now an earlier
book that I wrote called the spectrum
was based on the idea that if you don't
have heart disease if you're just trying
to lose a few pounds or get your
cholesterol or blood pressure down to
say instead of saying here's your diet
because part of what we've learned is
that even more than being healthy people
want to feel free and as soon as I tell
somebody do this and don't do that and
eat this and don't eat that they
immediately wanted to be opposite and
when I lecture sometimes I say it's like
the first dietary intervention when God
said don't eat the Apple and that in
gussto Helen that was God talking our
seventeen year old son something's bad
for them that it's like motorcycles are
dangerous that just makes it cool you
know it's a you actually kind of
productive so to say look if you go on a
diet chances you're gonna go off it
because diets are all about what you
can't have and what you must do and then
when you go off and then you then said
you kind of beat yourself up with all
this you know anger and shame and guilt
and humiliation and those are really
toxic to you those actually are bad for
you so and if you say well I you know
might as well just finish the pot of ice
cream you know because I'm a bad person
and the whole language of behavioral
change has this kind of fascist you know
moralistic wagging your finger you know
I cheated on my diet you know or once
you call foods you get are bad it's in
very small steps to say I'm a bad person
there's a bad food it's all just a mess
and so and that sometimes the rap that
we get oh you're the Danny you know this
kind of says you know this is all about
enjoying life and really having pleasure
so I say look instead of me telling you
what you want to do and instead of
calling foods good or bad we said Group
one or the healthiest foods group five
at least healthy foods to the degree you
move in that direction there's a
corresponding benefit you know when I
began doing these studies I thought the
younger people with less severe disease
would do better but I was wrong it
wasn't how old or how sick they were the
more they changed the better they got at
any age which is a really empowering
message to give people right I think
there's this idea that oh if you're 78
you're just - it's not at all we found
there's no upper limit to that and so
what I do is I'll say ok what do you
want to accomplish you say well I want
to
ten pounds I want to get my blood
pressure down ten points or my LDL down
50 points whatever it's a great what are
you doing now oh I'm eating mostly
unhealthy Group four and five foods okay
how much are you willing to change oh no
one's ever asked me that before they're
always just telling me what to do oh I
don't know I'll eat less of the
unhealthy Group four and five and a more
than one through three but let's still
eat some of the unhealthy foods too
great how much exercise you're getting
well not that much how much you willing
to do well walk a half an hour a day
cool how much yoga meditation are you a
zero how much are you willing to do I'll
meditate twenty minutes a day great how
much love and support do you have not
enough at all make a point to spend more
time with my friends and family boom
that's it okay well support that degree
of change if they indulge yourself one
if they indulge themselves one day it
doesn't mean they cheated or they failed
or they're bad just get healthier the
next you forget to exercise one day you
do a little more than X you don't have
any judgment take the judgment out of it
a journey of discovery yeah it's like
never stepping into the same river twice
beginner's mind you know if you can sort
of feel like one again it's so important
that people feel like they are making
this choice you know it - you know
you're your doctor your spouse whomever
else they're consultants but ultimately
you're the only CEO for yourself and so
I just I think you know if you people
take it on as their own scientific
experiment so just try it try so that's
what how to weeks six weeks you know you
feel don't trust us and then if that
degree of change after two weeks for six
weeks is enough to accomplish your goals
great that's it if not you say okay I
wanted to get down 50 points that came
down 30 points great look you're on the
right track just do a little more you
get the rest of the rock and then it's a
most compassionate way because there's
no diet to get on there's no diet to get
off it's just saying it's it's
directional to the degree you move in
this direction there's a corresponding
benefit at any age right but as I'm sure
you've seen time and time again when you
give people that kind of control and
agency and they make a few changes and
they start to feel better than their
machine it's a Trojan horse I didn't
talked about right let's talk about
Alzheimer's a little bit
I had the suresies in here and they
spoke at length about the amazing work
and results that they're getting at at
Loma Linda with their Institute right
now you've mentioned at the outset that
this is also part of of what you're
addressing in the new book and that
you're hopeful through this new clinical
study that I guess you're about to
embark on who just sort of used to do
two starts that that you're going to be
able to see not just prevention but
reversal and it seems like reversal is
the Holy Grail with this nobody's been
really been able to figure out how to
reverse this well my mom died of
Alzheimer's and she was brilliant she
got her master's degree when she was 18
she and to see someone whose mind was so
brilliant kind of deteriorating was just
tragic in so many different levels so
and there are no good drugs for treating
or preventing Alzheimer's so it's a
perfect kind of virgin territory to look
at lifestyle changes without B it's kind
of like 40 years ago when we did our
heart disease reversal studies before
statins came out we can look at the
effects of lifestyle changes alone so
we're doing the first randomized trial
in collaboration with Bruce Miller who
runs the memory and aging Center at UCSF
and others like him Joel told Kramer and
others and we're gonna randomly divide
men and women who have early to moderate
Alzheimer's into two groups we're gonna
give one group the lifestyle
intervention but not the other and we'll
test both groups before and after and we
hope to be able to show because again
Alzheimer's is just yet another example
of a chronic disease that shares all
these same underlying mechanisms again
that's the whole point of the book is
that all of these different diseases
including Alzheimer's really are
different manifestations of the same
disordered mechanisms including chronic
inflammation and oxidative stress and so
on and so we really believe that these
same lifestyle changes that can reverse
all these other conditions will likely
reverse Alzheimer's and you know the
anecdotal case reports the studies there
have been the studies called like the
finger study and the mind study and
others that use less intensive
interventions can slow or stop the
progression of it just like there were
40 years ago less intensive
interventions could slower stop the rate
of heart disease progression we think a
more intensive intervention can actually
reverse it mm-hmm well it'll be
interesting to see so how long will this
study go on for like we break this down
how the
to call the protocol is we're taking a
hundred men and women and we're giving
them the program we're testing both
groups at baseline we're giving one
group the intervention for four months
but not the other we've learned that if
you tell a group in the control group
that they did them that they're not
going to get it then they do it on their
own that's what happened in the Women's
Health Initiative study where they spent
two billion dollars and the women in the
control group said hell with you we're
gonna do it anyway you can't keep us
from doing it it screws up everything
cuz you know then you know you don't
have any differences between the groups
but if you tell somebody in fact in the
very first heart disease study I
remember a guy got randomized to the
control group who really wanted to
change his lifestyle and he got such he
was so upset he got an Jenner and chest
pain and ended up in the coronary care
unit called me at four in the morning
said basically f you you know I'm up
you're gonna be up to you feel so I
learned that you know if you in our
study we're gonna say look if you end up
in the both groups are gonna get the
program one group just has to wait for
months and if you tell somebody you're
gonna get it in four months that's not
very long and please don't change during
that four months because it'll mess up
our study that's ethically defensible
and it works well test both groups again
after four months then we'll cross them
over give the first group an additional
four months the for the group that
didn't get it well they'll get it for
four months and test both groups again
after eight months right and the
protocol that you're gonna be using is
basically what's in the book it's exact
that's the thing that's that's what
makes that's why we're so excited about
this new book is that it distills the 40
years of work to say look I'm done with
all these diet Wars I'm all these
debates look it every disease we've
studied gets better every mechanism we
look at gets better and these same
mechanisms are what caused all these
different diseases manifesting in
different ways and here's how you do it
and boom that's it you know you know it
starts with a quote by Albert Einstein
who said if you can't make it simple you
don't understand it well enough you know
and the people don't know anything can
make a civil out of ignorance but the
people who spend their whole lives doing
something like I'm not sure if I asked
you what the best way to exercise was
you know you could reduce it down to
something really simple whereas somebody
else might just kind of go meander
around so it's basically the essence of
what we've learned in in in a very
simple way without being simplistic and
tying it all together in this unifying
theory about why these same lifestyle
changes are so powerful in every way we
can
we can look at mm-hmm you want anything
today amen do I hear a hallelujah I know
you don't want to get pulled into the
diet Wars but I got a couple questions I
asked you before before I let you go and
and really for me it's it's more it's
more of just getting your perspective on
these issues too to set the record
straight run I think things that confuse
a lot of people you know for example
what's wrong with the Mediterranean diet
I heard olive oil is good like well you
know my doctor told me to go on the
Mediterranean diet like just some of the
sort of things that that you know I know
for a fact are out there and perhaps
losing people it's a good question the
Mediterranean diet is a better diet that
most people eat no question but it's not
an optimal diet the big study that made
headlines was called the Preta Med study
and it it compared a quote Mediterranean
diet to a quote low-fat diet this is
part of the the meme that goes around
the low-fat is that you know they say oh
the Mediterranean was so much better
than low-fat diet so I looked at that
die I looked at that study very
carefully and it turned out that the
low-fat diet went from 39 percent fat to
36 percent fat you know hardly any
change at all they replaced fat with
sugar which is never a good idea and
even with all that they actually found
that there was no difference in
cardiovascular mortality or events in
the two groups there was a big
difference in stroke rate because the
Mediterranean diet people are encouraged
to eat salmon and fatty fish which have
the Omega threes in there and that keeps
blood from clotting and blood clots
account for 90% of stroke so they showed
a huge reduction in stroke but they
showed no difference in cardiovascular
events but they pulled the data together
so that it looked like there was an
overall reduction in everything but it
was really only an overall reduction in
stroke now we've been adding Omega
threes to our program for 30 years my
mentor at Harvard Alex Leif who was the
chief of Medicine came up with those
ideas and you can get them from fish oil
but you can also get them from plankton
based Omega threes I mean that's where
the fish get them from is from eating
the plane thing and so you know you can
get the benefits without the the other
stuff so a Mediterranean diet is better
than most most because it's mostly
fruits and vegetables and whole grains
and so on but you don't need the oils
you
be the the animal protein and if you can
go even further to reverse disease you
know there's the ounce of prevention a
pound of cure them the Mediterranean
diet for some people may be enough to
prevent disease but there's no study
that's ever shown that it can actually
reverse it whereas a Whole Foods
plant-based diet that's low in fat and
sugar especially when combined with
these other you know you know stress
management and exercise and social
support we found over and all over all
over and over can actually reverse
disease and to the degree you make these
changes now you show that much more
reversal but dr. Ornish I get all of my
beef from grass-fed organic that's
another gigantic you know telling people
what they want to hear it's you know
that's why I love in this game changers
filmed that James Cameron did the the
the meal that they gave these athletes
was a grass-fed organic chicken or beef
or pork and it's still you know when
they ate a plant-based meal they had
three to five hundred percent more
frequent erections than 10 to 15 percent
harder just one meal there's not a
single study showing that grass-fed beef
is healthier than regular beef it may be
a little bit higher in the omega-3s but
that's hardly the best way to get omegas
and lower and hormones and Lauren corn
maybe but you know even lowered hormones
is not to eat the beef in the first
place you know is it better it's
certainly better for the animal and but
it's it's it's not healthy it may be a
little less unhealthy but it's not good
for you mm-hmm alright so what do you
have to say to again I'm pulling you
into the diet war for me to be yeah so
so you had these epic debates with with
Atkins going way back but you know that
tradition has sort of been inherited by
Gary Gary Taubes you know tie Colts you
know who else is part of this markali
movement Mark Hyman
well mark mark mark maybe less so than
Gary but yeah I would really I would put
him in there as well
you know mark wrote a book called eat
fat to get thin yeah in that book by the
way has four pages on my work and he's
any mark just makes stuff up it's
unfortunate
say that about most people but he put in
their Dean's diet they in the 1998 JAMA
study they gain weight their cholesterol
went up and their arteries got more
clogged I said mark they're their
cholesterol went down by an average of
40% they lost an average of 24 pounds
and their arteries had some reversal
after one year and even more reversal
after five years what are you talking
about and and you know I had to threaten
to sue him to get him to change anything
I was a transcription error I was like
just stupid people skew it's all about
perception and so data can be presented
in lots of ways in a perception issue
this was just wrong you know let me just
be really clear about that then Gary
Thomas says things like and David Ludwig
all calories are not alike fat calories
I mean carb calories calorie for calorie
make you fatter than fat calories so
Kevin hall at the United National suits
of health did a metabolic ward study
which meant that they actually people
had people in in the hospital for two
weeks where they can literally control
every calorie that they ate and measure
it and what did they find they did find
that all calories are not the same but
the opposite of what the Gary Taubes and
David Ludwig's and others say that
calorie for calorie fat calories make
you were 67% more likely to end up in
body fat than than carb calories now
again it's not fat versus carbs they're
both important and again it's not just
fat versus carbs it's animal protein but
this idea that somehow that it's all you
know that that fat is good for you and
that it's all carbs is is just you know
ridiculous and it's unfortunate because
telling people what they want to hear it
gets picked up it turns into a meme it's
broadcast you know what we talked about
earlier Americans have been told eat
less fat they're fatter than ever low
fat is dead it's all sugar we're eating
more fat than effort you know we're
eating more sugar than ever we need to
reduce both of them it's people are
always looking for that magic bullet
that Anne talked about the reductionist
approach it's all of these things that
make a difference yeah I I think you
know the gern the journal the the
journalistic kind of culture has a big
role to play in this as well because
it's being driven by cliques and they
need those headlines to be Beatty and
and they're gonna jump on the next sort
of crazy diet thing you know to drive
traffic and it's just exacerbating well
that's the problem
eugen because you know I mean it's hard
to have print media I mean there's so
many the media are going under even Time
magazine you know Marc Benioff thank
goodness bought it recently but it was
about to go into the trash bin just
because and so they're always journals
are not immune from that either you know
they have what they call the impact
factor and so the more likely your
article is to get picked up in the
mainstream media the more impact you
have so they're always looking for the
things that are they think are gonna
generate headlines so there was the
British Medical Journal had this article
this goes back to the saturated fat
thing you were saying earlier and in the
abstract it said saturated fat was not
related to heart disease diabetes or all
cause mortality and that made headlines
around the world
I looked at that study very carefully
and I saw they looked at the data two
ways one was the the adjusted way where
they just looked at the raw data and the
other was what they call adjust it they
only put the adjusted data in the
abstract but when you adjust for they
would adjust for dietary cholesterol but
invariably because of cholesterol and
saturated fat often travel together
you're adjusting for both so it wiped
out the difference since but if you
looked at the raw data the unadjusted
data which was in the manuscript itself
but then it goes past the absolute
nobody goes past the abstract but I did
and so I looked at it and said what did
they find they found that saturated fat
was statistically significantly and
clinically significant linked with each
one was increased risk of diabetes heart
disease prostate breast and colon cancer
boom didn't even make it into the
abstract okay and so that's the problem
because they know that if they can say
something that's that tells people what
they want to hear and it's gonna make
headlines their impact factor goes up so
so much of this is really unfortunate
and you know with Donald Trump and and
you know facts are not facts and you
know they're you know it we that's what
to me I think we really just need to be
absolutely clear about what the facts
show because if we can't believe that
then we have we just have chaos any you
know it's it's I've said this before but
it's right
out of the playbook from the cigarette
manufacturers less you no doubt is our
product and if you just cast the
slightest amount of doubt and it
paralyzes people and just keeps them
stuck in their unhealthy ways well
that's you know with some people like
Mark you know they're like the Donald
Trump of medicine they just make stuff
up you know because they know it'll sell
books I mean I can't really attribute
motivation anybody but I can just say
that you know buyer beware you know and
it's unfortunate but it's just that's
how people get rewarded these days
mm-hmm you know there's some aspect of
read the fine print follow the money
but also at be your own experiments you
know see see what the results so for
yourself I think there's no crater time
that's a good point because you know if
you just do it for a week you will see
the benefits you do you're in of one
study if you do it for ten days to two
weeks check your cholesterol check your
weight check your blood pressure you'll
see the difference if you have heart
disease we found a 91% reduction in the
frequency of chest pain due to heart
disease in three in twenty four days we
found that we could show significant
improvements in blood flow in the
ability of the heart to pump blood in
three to four weeks you don't if the
intervention is intensive enough again
because these underlying biological
mechanisms are so dynamic most people
feel so much better so quickly it then
reframes the reason for making these
changes from fear of dying or fear of
something bad happening which is not
sustainable to joy and pleasure and
feeling that which really are right all
right so undo it walk me through the
protocol I mean it's everything that
we've been talking about right doctor
pleased or stress less love more I mean
really it's that simple
and I think if you are trying to reverse
a disease you get to practice stress
management for up to an hour a day and
it becomes just as one example that's
something that initially is like well
how am I going to find an hour to do
this but within days let alone weeks
it's like how could I go a day without
doing this it's become such an essential
part of how I feel and how
I identify with myself if you're trying
to reverse Aziz but again if you don't
if you're just trying to stay healthy
then for whatever degree you do it
there's a corresponding benefit
precisely but she's absolutely right but
fee undo it is again it's based on the
idea that our bodies have this
remarkable capacity to begin healing and
much more quickly than we had once
realized if we treat the underlying
cause and the underlying cause comes
down to what we eat how we respond to
stress how much exercise we get how much
love and support we have and the more
diseases we study and the more
biological mechanisms we look at the
more evidence we have to show why these
simple changes are so powerful people
think oh it has to be a new drug and a
laser or something really high-tech and
expensive and I think our unique
contribution has to been to use these
very high-tech expensive
state-of-the-art scientific measures to
prove how powerful these very simple and
low tech and low-cost interventions can
be but what makes this book unique is
that we were taken all this 40 years of
work and reduce it down to its essence
you know Steve Jobs used to say he was
more proud of what he left out of the
iPhone than what he put into it because
you know if you really understand
something you can reduce it down to
what's really important most and leave
all the other stuff out yeah so if
somebody's listening to this and they
realize that they need to make some
changes
they're headed down that path but
they're living in a place where there is
no lifestyle medicine clinic they're not
they can't come and see you and their
doctor is telling them look you got to
be on these drugs that's the way it is
and you know just get with the program
that's very you know emotionally it's
very difficult like oh I have to go in
and challenge my doctor my doctor is
telling me to do this you're I'm
listening to a podcast this guy's
telling me to do this radical thing and
now I got to go tell them I'd you know
it's frightening for a lot of people
it's intimidating so how can we you know
walk somebody through taking those
initial steps to you know put the best
foot forward well first of all I think
that if you find a doctor that's more
supportive that's a good thing but even
if you don't say okay I'm on blood
pressure pills let's say they might say
or let's say they're on high cholesterol
lowering drugs okay so I'm gonna go on
those drugs like my doctor wanted to do
but I'm gonna change my lifestyle too
and I'm gonna get a blood pressure cuff
to measure my blood pressure at home and
chances are what they'll find is over
the next few weeks their blood pressure
starts to get so low
to low back to the doctor said gosh your
blood pressure is really doing well
let's and they say well I'd like to cut
back my dose because I'm starting to
pass out here and my blood pressure has
been like 90 over 50
oh okay well let me cut it in half okay
and then suddenly now you become the
teacher for your doctor because they are
we don't we don't might totally I wrote
a paper with a some of my colleagues
where we found like the average amount
of nutrition is like an hour per year in
medical school and even that's like you
know a vitamin C gotta change well I
think again right the first one is gonna
change that but the point is is that you
can become a teacher for your doctor by
your example which is always the best
teacher and if somebody wants to seek
out a lifestyle medicine doctor are
there online resources where they can go
and see who's yeah and it's so brilliant
she developed the our website our whole
learning management system you know
she's so beautiful that people don't
realize how brilliant you know it really
is this man for a lot of people but
orange calm she designed completely
everything on there is free so there's a
lot of information there's testimonials
that maybe you can just talk about it
because you built it yeah so basically
there is a what we call a site directory
on Ornish comm and so you can find a
site nearest you we also do residential
retreats so if you can't do a nine week
outpatient model somewhere
geographically close to you you can
pardon me come join us for a residential
more immersion retreats which by the way
Medicare will pay for if they have money
many insurance companies are expanding
the coverage beyond heart disease to
include diabetes or sometimes even tor
more risk factors and with the new book
undo it's we're going to be developing a
new community platform that will be
direct-to-consumer so to the general
public
a place that you can start or join a
support group based on your lifestyle
goal so really for free because we
really see that that support piece is
once you have you say okay I have this
up this lifestyle goal how am I going to
get there well support is not only
supportive but it helps you be
accountable and it makes it more fun
I mean if you're not having fun it's not
close to staying
so we can match you with people who
share your goal and together you can
achieve it that's a beautiful thing you
guys it's a set of better people I love
how you guys are working together - it's
really cool actually I will say you know
there were some there was some
turbulence from time to time especially
I was a little bit of a menage a 12 with
the publisher editor but not morally the
only chapter we thought about was the
love chapter was the irony was not last
she loves to say that but it was more
because it was the first chapter that we
wrote so it really defined our writing
style and voice separated yet together
yes and also I wanted to be a little
more self disclosing about our personal
life and Ann is this your first book
this is my first footer yeah it is
exciting yeah after 20 years it felt
like low-hanging fruits yeah it's a
beautiful thing I mean to have so many
different I feel like I'm married this
harem of different people because you
play somebody if we played with so many
different roles of each other it's
really beautiful it keeps it really
interesting we did fortunately in
undoing it's we're able to fall in love
again more than ever because I do think
that when you join forces with people
who share your sense of mission whether
it's a lifestyle goal or a partnership
of any sort it's a thrilling experience
to be able to do things that you
couldn't do alone there's others it's
also an opportunity to confront your
character defects yes you're working
with your spouse or your partner on
something that you feel very strongly
about
you're gonna you're it's all gonna come
out right it's for sure and that's an
opportunity to work through that which
can lead you to deeper intimacy or just
explode the relationship like I work
with Julie on a bunch of stuff I want
this this work yeah and we try to be
clean mirrors for each other because you
know we you know they say you teach what
you want to learn and we're always
learning and growing and we can reflect
back to
each other while we both what we most
need to hear and because we trust each
other so much we know it's coming from a
good place even if it isn't always
expressed as clearly or cleanly as we'd
like right all right well we got to wrap
this up but my favorite question to kind
of end these conversations that I have
with with doctors and medical
professionals is this
if you awoke in a parallel universe and
found yourself in the position of being
Surgeon General what are the policies
and changes that you would like to see
implemented like what would your what
would your agenda be well I've actually
thought about that because you were in a
position where that was a possibility
and yeah more than a possibility but
yeah I'd like to see that again our work
is all about dealing with the cause and
so I'll give you an example I I
consulted in 1999 with the CEO of
McDonald's and people that I thought I
was lost more in line because I thought
you know at 43 million customers a day
and even incremental change on that
level can be good so I was able to
persuade them to put salads on the menu
not necessary for the right reasons but
it basically cell is junk food you're
gonna be like the Big Tobacco they're
gonna come after you at least if you
could say that we have salads then at
least you could say we're offering a
variety of choices so they did but the
problem and they were great salads they
had edamame and you know all kinds of
wonderful things in them but they
ultimately failed because the salad was
595 the burgers 99 cents and if you're
on a fixed income you get more calories
for your buck by eating junk food
because the junk food is subsidized in
the healthy food is not and also it
doesn't price into the real real cost of
society so if I were Surgeon General
I've tried to do this when senator
Harkin was the senator is to work with
the farm bill to work with you know
subsidizing healthy foods and and and
not the the junk foods making them more
plentiful and available to work with
I've also you know consult with some of
the big food processors to say you know
can you make healthier foods you know
even healthier versions of the foods you
know you've just to move in that
direction and again to in our fee for
service to make the kinds of lifestyle
medicine programs that we've been doing
greatly expanded because we know that
we've already shown that we can cut
health care costs in half in the first
year at 5% of people account for 80% of
healthcare costs these are the 5% with
chronic diseases and like 75% of all
healthcare costs it's up to 80 to 86
percent of the three point six trillion
dollars we spent last year on healthcare
costs which were really mostly sick care
costs are for treating chronic diseases
that we now know are largely preventable
or even reversible through change your
lifestyle and then we can make better
care available to more people at lower
costs and again the only side effects
are good ones yeah that's a worthy
agenda what would you do for my I think
those are all like systemic things to do
and so again that would be sort of like
top-down and I'd say from bottom up I
think it's really from the earliest ages
really allowing people to get the right
starts from our education system to
integrate obviously nutrition the value
of physical activity the self-awareness
in our tools for stress which is also
epidemic in our society and the ability
to have these support groups I think
they should be part of I think it would
be very beneficial for them to be better
integrated into our school systems into
the way we work because we're spending
more time either at school as a student
or at work as a as an adult we need to
not say this is how I live when I'm not
working or when I'm not at school we
need to have this more integrated way of
living like Alice Waters has ever there
Edible Schoolyard she'll have vegetables
growing this is where they come from you
don't really integrate that into their
lives it's beautiful well school
launches a disaster and the education
system as a whole needs revamping as we
usher in the age of AI the idea that
we're still teaching kids the way that
we were teaching them and the you know
dawn of the Industrial
saying well you know I worked with Allen
Hospice use this in Dan Glickman when he
was Secretary of Agriculture back in
1993 to see if we could change the
school lunch program and there was such
pushback from the industry I was
astonishing yeah like like like farm
subsidies in the farm bill there's
there's so much invested in in that
system difficult to overcome it but you
know that's another but I do believe
that over time things are directionally
moving in a good drum there's a
convergence of forces that really make
this the right idea at the right time at
the same time that studies are showing
that stents don't work in stable
patients that men with early-stage
prostate cancer who do nothing live as
long after ten years as those who have
surgery radiation that getting your
blood sugar down if you have diabetes
with drugs doesn't work nearly as well
as getting it down with lifestyle we're
also saying that these lifestyle changes
can reverse and prevent most of these
chronic diseases yeah there's plenty of
room for optimism but it's like an arms
race right eighty-six percent of
healthcare costs go into these diseases
eighty percent of Americans obese or
overweight one out of every three die
it's like so what's what's gonna happen
for you know like as you know it's like
work it we're getting greater and
greater awareness around healthy habits
and lifestyle practices that can alter
this landscape but at the same time the
number of people that are that are that
are dying and becoming disabled from
these diseases is like a mushroom cloud
it's true and if you look at those CDC
maps of the you know percentage of
people are obese over time it looks like
a you know an alien force is taking over
the country which in some ways it is
Margaret Mead says you know change
doesn't say the same that change has
always happened not by you know 90% of
the population but a much smaller
leaving less than 20% it's really a
small group of organized individuals
that are devoted to change and progress
and that's the way it's always happened
I mean you look at the women's suffrage
movement or any big change civil rights
it always was a small group of people it
again well organizing to vote
to their mission so we don't have to go
after you know we just got to get that
critical mass and we have to turn that
tide and we go where the energy is so we
start with the people where that
awareness is art and the readiness is
already there
and we just get the movement going about
what you're doing I said the same thing
you're you're raising the awareness is
the most powerful thing that can be one
of the great things about new media is
is your your own distribution platform
and a message like yours has
traditionally been throttled because you
know the dr. Oz's and the doctors and
the network TV shows and the whatever
are underwritten by the pharmaceutical
companies and the fast food industry and
the breakfast serie is like they don't
want you talking about what you're
talking about on their television
program because it will negatively
impact their bottom line and so I think
it then becomes incumbent upon podcast
hosts and bloggers and you know
self-publishing authors anybody who can
be a vessel for a healthy message
outside of the traditional constrictions
of our traditional media system to
really advance you know the work that
you're doing well just to be an
unabashed requests of people if this is
something that appeals to you you know
pre-order our book on Amazon or Barnes
and Noble because the publishers pay
attention to that you know and and if it
then gets on the bestseller list is
fortunately all six of my earlier books
have then that generates its own
awareness and its own interest and then
you know we can ultimately affect change
in a much larger group of people are
magnified in that way yeah cool all
right parting words somebody's listening
to this they're like okay I'm ready I've
been stuck for a long time I'm ready to
undo it like you know just leave me with
some kind of inspiration or just a
starting point person the starting point
is your personal answer to the question
of why do you want to live longer and
not just to live longer but to live
better that's that's where it all
comes from your beautiful human being in
order thank you both thank you so much
for honor to feel this time with you
guys today
much love and and best of luck with the
new book everybody pre-order it
immediately do it available wherever you
buy find books of course Ornish calm
PMR i.org right is the foundation
website any other places where people
can track you down
rich roll co the podcast alright you
guys so awesome come back to talk to me
again thank you guys thank you
[Music]
you